las vegas mom is hoping you can help
find her only daughter tonight jessica
pappin has been missing since there's a
last scene in the southwest valley 8
news now reporter sally jademio is near
flamingo in decatur with what the family
is saying about her disappearance sally
yeah this area near flamingo in decatur
was where 34 year old jessica pappin was
last seen her mother is concerned
tonight as she says she had problems in
the past
my worst nightmare it feels surreal like
it's i can't believe this is really
happening you see the flyers of other
people i never thought it would be me
carrie mimi is jessica pappin's mother
she tells me her daughter went missing
thursday she's an addict and she was in
sober living
she had just finished a 90-day rehab
they caught her on a breathalyzer and
nobody's seen her scent mimi is
concerned that no one has seen jessica
and jessica has not been in contact with
anyone never ever ever in her entire
life gone more than a day without
texting me we've driven everywhere we've
tried everything and i just now found
out that she has not used her bank card
since thursday no phone no bank so i i
just fear the worst right now nimi says
jessica was last seen driving a red
mitsubishi mirage license j papin her
message to jessica if you're listening
there's nothing we can't get through
we'll do whatever we can to help please
just come home
now back out live carrie niemi says
there needs to be more awareness
surrounding mental health and addiction
now she also encourages anyone for
information to please contact metro
police immediately reporting live sally
jaramillo live local now